There's a wide world of Gradle
plugins out there created and
maintained by Gradle, its partners,
and by developers around the world.
To find documentation on plugins
included with Gradle by default,
check out the Gradle User Guide.
Specifically, Chapter 21 on
the standard Gradle plugins.
There are three broad types of plugins.
Language plugins for compiling
languages like Java or [INAUDIBLE].
Integration plugins for
creating different sorts of artifacts.
And software development
plugins that make
the software development process easier.
To find plugins written
by third parties,
check out the Gradle plugin
portal at plugins.gradle.org.
Here you can search for
plugins that will help you automate
whatever it is you're working on.
Now since these plugins
are provided by third parties and
aren't bundled with Gradle, there
needs to be a way to distribute them.
Just putting them under source
control leads to the same messes with
libraries or any other artifact.
Fortunately, Gradle's dependency
management can be used for
the dependencies required
by the build script itself.
If you click on any of
the available plugins.
You'll see a snippet for
using the plugin in your build.
The build script block means that this
configuration applies to the execution
of the build script itself and
not to the compilation or execution of
whatever project Gradle is building.
This block declares a maven
repository hosted by great deal and
a dependency on this particular plugin.
Also since this is
a quite common pattern.
There's a simpler way to
do the equivalent thing
using the plugins block.